Від початку конфлікту на сході
нелетальну допомогу Україні у оборонній сфері
надавали 18 країн. Від одягу до сучасних військових технологій.
Головний партнер – США.
Звідси – левова частка іноземних поставок для української армії.
Позашляховики типу "Гамві", прилади нічного бачення, контрартилерійські радари,
обмундирування, тактичні безпілотники "Ворон", медичне обладнання.
Щоправда, за словами експертів, досі Вашингтон надавав техніку з обмеженими можливостями –
начебто аби не дратувати Росію.
Станом на 2017 рік
загальна вартість допомоги зі Штатів
сягнула 650 мільйонів доларів.
Це включно із оплатою фахівців,
які тренують українських спецпризначенців та консультують армію.
Бронежилети, захисні костюми для саперів, шоломи, зимова уніформа. Це неповний поставок з Канади
– другого серед партнерів.
Її допомога перевищила 12 мільйонів доларів.
Крім того, двісті канадських тренерів підвищували
кваліфікацію українських офіцерів.
Сухпайки, житній хліб тривалого зберігання,
набори одягу і термо-білизни.
Польща лише офіційно допомогла на майже 7 мільйонів доларів –
найбільше з країн ЄС.
Навігаційні прилади, засоби зв'язку, лептопи, бронежилети та медикаменти  -
це підтримка Україні від ще однієї європейської країни –
Великобританії.
Її військові проводили тренінги з покращення
оперативно-тактичних навичок для українських бійців.
5 мільйонів доларів - це обсяг допомоги Британії, і стільки ж дала Австралія.
Не залишилися осторонь і у НАТО.
Торік альянс створив 5 трастових фондів із допомоги Україні
у численних сферах -
від командування і зв'язку
до протидії кіберзагрозам та медичної реабілітації.
У фонди надійшло вже понад 15 мільйонів доларів.
Німеччина лікує українських солдатів з особливо важкими пораненнями.
Також ФРН чи не головний донор – мобільних будиночків,
польових кухонь,
радіаторів та зимового одягу.
Але досі Берлін не надавав Києву ані зброї,
ані матеріалів для армії.
Якщо витрати самої України на оборону торік -
4,5 мільярди доларів,
то іноземна допомога склала близько 360 мільйонів.
У Міноборони наголошують,
що українській армії терміново потрібні такі види зброї
як протитанкові ракети "Джевелін" та  безпілотні літаки-розвідники.
Окремі європейські експерти радять урядам ЄС озброювати,
а не лише гуманітарно допомагати українському війську.
Після візиту в Вашингтон Петро Порошенко заявив,
що за 2-3 місяці в Україну
приїде керівник Пентагону -
і США усе-таки ухвалять рішення про надання Україні зброї.